Hoy vamos a hablar de un tema fascinante: Donald Trump. Con este vídeo empezamos una
nueva playlist en la que nos vamos a
dedicar a las elecciones americanas un
tema que lógicamente teníamos que tratar
en un canal como éste. Donald Trump
es uno de los candidatos a las primarias
republicanas y hay un consenso en todo
Europa en que es idiota.
Aunque todavía hay gente que piensa que bueno, siendo un empresario de
éxito como él no puede no puede
equivocarse. Pocos se han dedicado a
desgranar sus propuestas una a
una y ver si merece la pena lo que dice
este hombre
nosotros lo hemos hecho y la conclusión
que hemos sacado bueno, Couto nos la puede decir mejor
Pues Fonseca, la conclusión que
hemos obtenido es que este hombre es un
auténtico peligro público no porque
sea probable que vaya a ser presidente
de Estados Unidos porque lo cierto es
que esto es verdaderamente improbable
pero sí por el caldo de cultivo que
está generando en la política y en la
sociedad americana
este personaje populista, victimista y
egomaníaco. Hoy vamos a ver por qué, Fonseca.
Por si alguien no lo sabe, Donald Trump es el candidato con más papeletas de ganar
las primarias republicanas este año, es
un señor que ya era conocido antes de
entrar en política por ser uno de los
hombres más ricos del mundo. Ahora con
sus propuestas también está
demostrando que es uno de los hombres más fachas del mundo.
Pero Fonseca, facha
de verdad su programa electoral es un auténtico delirio.
Sí porque propone
propone auténticas barbaridades como
por ejemplo deportar a 11 millones de
inmigrantes ilegales mandarles a su
casa pero mandando a la policía.
Sí, mandando más que a toda población Andalucía, mandando a la policía
metiéndoles en camiones y mandándoles
de vuelta. Es tremendo de hecho el señor
Donald Trump una de sus citas más
célebre de la campaña es que él no va
a romper las unidades familiares, Fonseca
porque va a deportar a los a los papás,
a las mamás y a los niños todos juntos.
Lo que es además inconstitucional
porque muchos de esos niños ya son
ciudadanos americanos según naces en
Estados Unidos en territorio americano
eres ciudadano americano y esa
ciudadanía no te la pueden revocar.
Claro Fonseca, pero es que al señor Donald Trump la constitución americana le importa más bien poco
Luego además también propone
levantar un muro, una
una muralla en la frontera entre EE.UU. y
México
Sí, sí. Un muro de más de 1.000 km con alambradas perros, metralletas y nadie sabe muy bien para
qué porque lo cierto Fonseca es que
desde el año 2009 la población
inmigrante mexicana en EE.UU. se
viene reduciendo y hoy hay más
inmigrantes que llegan cada año de
India y China que de México.
Sí, los emigrantes además llegan a un aeropuerto. Bueno, tú has estado ahí.
Claro, es que la verdad es que la mitad de los inmigrantes ilegales han llegado en
avión. Llegan y cuando vence su visa, se quedan.
A ver tú has estado ahí en EE.UU., has estado en California, en Nuevo México
Sí, en Nevada Fonseca si yo
he tenido la oportunidad de
conocer muy bien EE.UU. sobre
todo los estados del sur que son los
estados en los que más población
hispana hay, y te puedo decir lo mismo que
te diría cualquier persona que haya
estado en el terreno, en el lugar
y es que no hay ningún problema ni de
adaptación y de criminalidad con la
población hispana
los hispanos llegaron a EE.UU. a
trabajar con tú vas a un Burger King o
una tienda las personas que te
encuentras en aquellos trabajos con
menor retribución son hispanos y de
hecho fonseca te voy a decir más
según todos los estudios la tasa de
delincuencia en términos comparables de
la población hispana es menor que la
de la población que ha nacido en
EE.UU. -que la población local- o
sea fíjate tú qué problemas.
O sea que no tiene ningún sentido a la fijación que tiene Donald Trump con los mexicanos
a los que además quiere hacer que paguen
el muro. ¡Con un par de narices! El muro ese
que cuesta 8.000 millones de dólares
quiere que lo pague el gobierno mexicano
no entiendo muy bien cómo
les va a convencer pero...
Bueno, esto Fonseca encaja muy bien con el espíritu
imperialista del señor Donald Trump
porque no sólo quiere hacer pagar el muro a los mexicanos es
que además ha anunciado que a todos los
europeos nos va a hacer pagar un tributo
a los EE.UU. en cuestión de defensa y que además también va a ir a
los países de Oriente Medio como Arabia
Saudita y les va a hacer pagar también
un tributo como si fuesen países
vasallos como si fuesen
colonias del siglo XIX.
Te imaginas tú a Donald Trump yendo ahí a
hablar con el rey de Arabia Saudí
diciéndole "oye mira que me vas a tener que
pagar aquí un impuesto así porque
me ha salido a mí de donde no te digo..." Y en fin…
Bueno es que no tiene ningún
sentido pero fíjate ha llegado a decir
que va a invadir militarmente Irak y
Siria, o sea gran parte de Oriente Medio, y
que se va a quedar directamente con el
petróleo porque dice que va a pagar la
ocupación militar con el petróleo que
directamente va a explotar en Irak y en
otros países de Oriente Medio, o sea
imagínate pero como si fuesen auténticas colonias
Sin embargo, en la
economía, en lo que es la la política
económica se parece más a Pablo
Iglesias que a Angela Merkel.
Desde luego, Fonseca. De hecho la mayor
fijación que tiene el señor Donald Trump
es contra el libre comercio
está totalmente en contra del libre
comercio está en contra del tratado de
libre comercio que se está negociando
entre Europa y EE.UU., está en
contra del tratado de libre comercio que
recientemente se ha aprobado entre EE.UU.
y países del pacífico, e incluso...
Lo del NAFTA, el tratado entre Canadá, México y EE.UU.
que es un tratado que lleva 20
años en funcionamiento y lo quiere
quitar, o sea, el tío no es para nada
pro-negocio ni muchísimo menos.
Todo lo contrario, de hecho fíjate, el NAFTA que ha sido todo un éxito
volviendo al caso de México es que el
NAFTA ha conseguido que las relaciones
comerciales entre EE.UU. y
México alcancen cada año los 500.000
millones de euros, México ya es el
tercer socio comercial de EE.UU.
y genera muchísimos millones
de trabajo en estados unidos
Sin embargo, como buen populista, quiere
triplicar el gasto público porque dice
que quiere gastar muchísimo más en
ejército…
Sí, quiere gastar muchísimo más en ejercito porque dice, Fonseca, que el ejército de EE.UU. es muy
pequeñito
A pesar de que hoy ya gastan más que los
20 países siguientes en el ranking
juntos, pero no sólo el ejército es
qué también ha anunciado que quiere llenar el
país de trenes de alta velocidad, de
autopistas y de infraestructuras de todo tipo
O sea que no tiene nada que ver con la austeridad de Merkel, por ejemplo
Nada más lejos de Merkel, pero además el señor Donald
Trump quiere realizar la
cuadratura del círculo
no sólo quiere aumentar el gasto
público, no sólo quiere cerrar sus
mercados al libre comercio sino que
además también ha dicho que
prácticamente va a eliminar la mayor
parte de los impuestos, por ejemplo, el
impuesto sociedades el impuesto los
beneficios de las empresas
lo va a eliminar, cuando en EE.UU. está en torno al 35% - 40%
Quiere convertirse en una especie de Singapur, una especie de paraíso fiscal
Bueno es que el impuesto de la renta el tipo
máximo lo va a bajar del 40% al 15%, pocos países en el mundo tienen esos
tipos y por supuesto gastando más.
Yo he oído que es el candidato favorito de Putin
o sea que Putin ha dicho públicamente
que si él fuera americano votaría por D. Trump
Sí, y D. Trump le ha correspondido Fonseca diciendo que Putin es uno de sus referentes
políticos, o sea imagínate que panorama
Lo cual dice ya mucho del campeón o sea
si Putin te apoya es que algo estás
haciendo mál
Sí, pero ya sabes Fonseca
que todo el mundo dice que como ha sido
un gran empresario y un empresario de mucho
éxito que eso le avala su proyecto
político
Bueno es que tampoco ha sido
ahí estoy en
desacuerdo porque no ha sido un gran
empresario realmente fue un tío que
heredó la empresa de su padre que era
una empresa inmobiliaria, que ya por
aquel entonces unos años 70 era una
empresa multimillonaria, y bueno hay
algunos estudios que dicen que si en vez
de continuar el negocio lo hubiera
vendido todo y lo hubiera invertido en
bolsa, en un valor normal y
corriente o sea en el S&P (500)
sin más ahora mismo sería más
rico de lo que ya es
con lo cual tampoco se puede decir que sea dinero suyo...
No, y de hecho Fonseca, ha rozado en muchas ocasiones la
auténtica bancarrota empresarial, y
también personal, y además siempre
todos sus negocios han tenido una
aureola de juego sucio, siempre ha estado
al límite de la ley, por ejemplo pues
para no pagar a trabajadores o
no pagar a proveedores cuando las
empresas iban mal
Sí, cuando quebraron la cadena de casinos que tenía no pago a los trabajadores
Claro, porque cuando justo antes de que le
declarasen la quiebra, Fonseca
el señor Donald Trump se había
cercionado de saquear la caja de la
empresa pagándose comisiones de
gestión salarios
bueno, y por todo tipo de conceptos
auténticas fortunas
O sea, en conclusión diríamos que es un payaso, ¿pero un payaso peligroso o no?
Un payaso peligroso y además misógino, porque fíjate Fonseca, ¿sabes lo que ha llegado
a decirle señor Donald Trump? El señor
Donald Trump ha llegado a decir que
Hillary Clinton no sería una buena
presidenta porque ha sido incapaz de
satisfacer sexualmente a su marido
pero, ¿te puedes imaginar cuál es el nivel
político de este hombre?
Bueno, oye Couto pues vamos a
tener que cerrar
yo creo que ya hemos dejado claro lo que
propone el señor Trump y bueno
solamente decir que, por favor, que si
alguien quiere añadir algo, está en
desacuerdo de lo que decimos, por lo que
sea piensa que D. Trump ha venido
para recambiar para reformar la
política americana y le quiere defender o
hay algún votante de Donald Trump o él
mismo señor
Donald Trump quiere mandarnos algo pues oye, mandadnos un
comentario esto no deja de ser un
debate abierto
Bueno, el único problema Fonseca, es que
es que ya sabes que si se produce la
rocambolesca situación de que acabase
siendo Presidentes de EE.UU., cosa que
es muy improbable porque hoy no se
pueden ganar unas elecciones en EE.UU. sin contar con el apoyo de las
minorías, sobre todo de la población
negra y de la población hispana, nosotros
entraríamos automáticamente en una
lista negra
Sí bueno, tendremos
que ver qué pasa para aquel
entonces. Bueno oye, Couto un abrazo
Perfecto, Fonseca, un fuerte abrazo y oye
hasta otro día
Venga, hasta pronto.